ce sera mon bonjour merci d'être avec
nous le budget que la bombe vous êtes
vous êtes awa pour la conférence des
maires des grandes municipalités
canadiennes vous avez rencontrés
représentant du gouvernement fédéral en
2015 monsieur trudeau avait dit vouloir
bâtir de nouveaux liens avec les maires
des grandes villes
est ce que ça fonctionne oui ça
fonctionne les liens du premier ministre
deux sont excellents avec les maires des
grandes villes nous dans les villes on
vit les problèmes quotidiens de
transport de logement
les intervenants de première ligne les
problèmes on les connaît quand tu montes
un certain niveau ça devient plus
intellectuel pas la fin ça devient les
différents souvent là alors l'idée il
comprend bien aux situations
il comprend très bien le travail qu'on
aura bien une situation évidemment ce
appelé à ce qu'ils vivent des com -
alors c'est pour ça que les relations
sont très bonnes on a un gouvernement
qui est progressiste les mains des
grandes villes sont des progressistes et
ce général dans le concret ce que ça
fonctionne pour l'argent mais cette rue
doivent être dits en 2015 et après il y
avait dix enfants vont investir dans les
villes on va vous en donner des sous on
va faire avancer des choses est ce que
vous la voyez cet argent c'est c'est
inégal ça dépend des régimes
ceux qui dirigent la première à québec
nous avons bien on vient de fermer un
financement pour le réseau de transport
structurellement fédéral c'est plus
nébuleux au niveau du logement mais
voyons voir à québec ça va bien si vous
allez au manitoba au manitoba secours
blake un alberto ça se complique
si vous parlez au mas de toronto de ses
relations avec le premier ministre
ontarienne s'est vu conseiller c est
donc large en bloc ou souvent dans
certains cas elle est utilisée pour les
faits pour lesquels son réseau était
voté alors il devrait on appelle ça de
monnaie dans une flow celle des casques
rapport au vin une frustration de votre
côté ou du côté fédéral vous en avez
parlé je présume cette semaine nous
haute savoie au québec ça va avec la
grammaire des gosses vont très bien ils
ont largement baissé parce que le secret
la dass et le gouvernement investit mais
il faut que le nouveau provincial
investissent voilà il ya des
gouvernements provinciaux peut-être
qu'ils ont qui n'ont pas les moyens ou
pour qu'ils se sentent ce ne sont pas
des priorités alors nous au québec ça va
bien parce que d'un transport structurel
de premier ministre hélas non non je
mange peu ce qu'il veut y est ce
toujours des questions de modalités de
ces jamais simple les relations
fédérales provinciales au québec
mais au québec on ne passe plus je vais
vous dirigez des mecs sont bien plus mal
pris que 12 ou est-ce que vous avez
l'impression d'être entendus par a3
passer quelques-uns et si vous avez
rencontré quand même une bonne partie du
gameplay on est entendu il vous écoute
oui nous écoutent le business des
finances vient chaque fois le premier le
dis à chaque fois vraiment un exemple la
façon dont ça se traduit comment comment
il vous écoute puis comment vous le
sentez by notre devoir nous autres on
lui donne des arguments non dans le fond
de travail c'est à dire dans la vie
voici ce qui se passe voici comment on
n'investit pas d'argent voici ce qui
nous manque puisqu'elle devrait être vos
priorités et moi je sais que justin
trudeau croit à ce qu'on lui dit
c'est quand des premiers suivis dans une
bulle tune entourage mais je sais qu'ils
nous écoutent pas ce qu'il nous connaît
nous sommes sur le terrain on dit au
quotidien il respecte beaucoup ça ne
vous le voyez concrètement quand vous
revenez à québec
vous parlez avec vos collègues pour leur
dire j'ai obtenu south je vais obtenir
sa houlette d'un programme
d'infrastructures qui était bâti etc
exane ouais on est mal
c'est exactement ce que des villes
voulaient et ça on sait qu'on l'a
influencé on sait qu'on l'a influencé
est ce qu'on avait à demander c'est ce
qui est il livré ses rares s'apprend
gouvernement fédéral de cazères ii
d'écouté à le troisième niveau qui les
villes
vous avez parlé de toi de logement
social ça semble être un peu une lacune
pour voir quel niveau je le sais pas ça
béton et les matchs du québec on est
tous pareils on sait pas s'il ya un
intérêt bouffe et déracinant très beau
québec on ne le sait pas où est ce que
ça bloque
on ne sait pas c'est ça notre je
voudrais vous dire je voudrais faire la
smat la mémoire et pour débloquer
quelque chose qu'on sait pour sa belle
on est en disant on insiste auprès du
gouvernement organisez-vous médecis est
toujours là relations fédérales
provinciales au québec qui est compliqué
c'est un peu c'est séculaire bah ouais
alors ça dure toujours
mais moi j'ai confiance qu'avec un
gouvernement pratique oppressé comme
celui de chez vous ça va se régler dans
votre cas ça veut dire comme cela vous
avez des besoins à québec qui sont
importants c'est pas grâce à la [ __ ]
un problème nous c'est que mon travail
alors
tout le monde l'a rejoint dans ses
poches le coût du logement est pas si
élevé mais on pense à l'avenir
puis on veut régler des problèmes
sociaux alors m'ont tous les logements
sociaux disponibles et prêts à tous
alors on est prêt nous a tous les freins
dans toi aussi on veut loger notamment
dont on conçoit que la vie de l'individu
normalement la base d'avoir un toit sur
la tête alors nous à la ville de québec
qu'on se préoccupe des problèmes sociaux
même c'est pas dans nos commandites de
notre liste de pages vous en avez des
projets rechange si vous n'avez pas de
terreau et pour les mettre ces logements
ne vous faîtes quoi non non il vaut
faire et on n'est pas la vérité c'est
qu'on n'a pas le choix faut les payer
plus cher alors ça coûte plus cher alors
ça donne rien commandé trop de
spectateurs devraient mur ça existe un
marché l'économie va bien québec alors
les terres plus jeunes faut les payer
pour ce pôle asie faites nous signe
nous vous en avions puis on vous parlait
parce que monsieur trudeau le
gouvernement trudeau sa priorité ou
l'une des priorités c'est justement le
logement social il en parle depuis un
mandat complet
est ce que quand vous arrivez devant lui
vous dites ça me coûte plus cher mais
pour mes terrains est ce qu'il ya une
écoute de ce côté là où ils le savent
que je vais être honnête ils le savent
et gérard obligé de l'asie vraiment vu
gouvernement fédéral est aussi l écoute
d mais ça fait quand même je faisais la
12e année là gérard est il sincère en
plus des fournées on a vu la défaite
qu'on a vus mais ils sont sincères ils
nous écoutent et la preuve c'est
vraiment la commande il de la création
des programmes d'infrastructures c'est
ce qu'on voulait vous a beaucoup entendu
parler de main d'oeuvre de pénurie de
main-d'oeuvre à québec
vous voudriez obtenir certains
programmes ou certaines dispenses pour
faire arriver la main d'oeuvre plus
rapidement en avez vous parlé ici est ce
que ça fonctionne j'en ai pas parlé
aujourd'hui ici parce que je veux pas
vraiment parler devant mes collègues
parce que je veux une exception ici
aujourd'hui on a à québec 24p l'impôt
est disponible on est on est plus en
plus d'un point
on n'a jamais vu ça ce que l'on veut
c'est le programme d'immigration qui
existe dans les maritimes qui était un
projet spécial qui a fait en sorte qu'au
lieu de prendre 18 à 24 mois avoir un
permis
apparaissent après six mois alors j'en
discute avec vous les gens discutent
avec les ministres du québec et j'ai
encore dit à justin pato comme on était
heureux d'avoir pablo rodriguez com est
né ce responsable
pablo rodriguez le texte il me répond
dans la même heure
j'ai jamais vu ça de ma vie alors et ils
le savent ils connaissent tous besoin
ils nous appuient maîtresse qui seront
capables de convaincre les masses
bureaucratie la mairie la machine
fédérale
je ne sais pas mais l'intention
politique et la volonté politique au
québec elle est là parce qu'à québec
c'est nous qui sommes au canada le plus
frappé par le manque de main-d'oeuvre et
dans les maritimes ça fonctionne à pors
alors on veut le même programme pour
québec
je suis rodriguez vous venez de
l'aborder c'est intéressant parce que
monsieur trudeau cette fois ci a dit je
vais je me prendrais lieutenant
québécois
ça fait une si grosse fernandez ça fait
une très grosse évidemment on avait
accès aux bureaux du premier ministre à
ses adjoints il ya pas de souci là mais
d'avoir un ministre élu au québec qui
veut se faire réélire pareil on a passé
près du même avoir présumément et
quelqu'un qu'on connaît depuis quelques
années un gars sensible à qui on ne peut
expliquer les choses
ça aide beaucoup revenons à vos projets
au québec troisième lieu on en a parlé
beaucoup cette semaine vous semble être
un peu plus chaud à l'idée le nouveau
tracé en notant que j'appuie le nouveau
projet nous ce qui nous inquiète l adage
c'était tout d'abord l'eau c'était ça
n'a aucun sens si on avait pour l'avenir
de grandes inquiétudes sur l'étalement
urbain et sol et aux murs bas c'est une
mauvaise idée
non ils ont proposé un projet qui va de
centre-ville à l'évident au centre-ville
de québec donc on est dans des
situations de densification sosa va très
bien ce sens vous voulez vous oui alors
une toute la densification c est clair
pour nous là et en plus à leurs projets
s'accroche à notre projet de transport
structurants alors on peut pas demander
mieux et c'est pour ça qu'on les appuis
on va travailler avec eux pour les aider
a commencé à québec on n'est pas de ciel
on les appuie à moins d'avis contraire
nous ont construit leur avez vous une
idée de la formule que ça devrait
prendre davantage de transports
transport collectif dans cette
infrastructure la dpi en jeu ce que vous
avez un modèle est aussi un regard de
possibles
tout ce que je veux savoir c'est que il
ya des clients qui m'arrive en transport
collectif qui vont connecter sur une
station de train - et qui vont embarquer
dans notre - et inversement vacances
arrivent ce genre il faut vous les
prenez on est équipée pour faire soyez
pas de souci on est équipée pour faire
ça alors au point de vue logistique n'y
a pas de problème pour ce qui est des
voitures supérieur
ça c'est pas c'est pas mes affaires
c'est la bombe prochaines élections
municipales 2021 allez vous présenter
je ne sais pas je vais voir nathan ce
que vous allez décider si on n'est pas
prêt si j'ai pas de place ici tu sais ce
qu'est ce qui fait la différence en vote
est-ce que vous avez l'impression qui a
encore des choses à faire pour vous
abbas était ce monsieur n'avait jamais
j'ai tellement plein dans la tête que je
n'arrêterai jamais pour le reste on
verra alors c'est une question j'ai eu
un avertissement il ya quelques mois
quant à ma santé doute rapport je vais
livrer des affaires très important qu'on
veut on fera le point de vente sur la
page des stries la santé ça va mais
manque un petit peu d'énergie mais ça
s'en vient mais juste la boum merci
beaucoup
l'ampli merci